hi my name is Meena I am based in China
I'm an Australian citizen I started a
company called peony capital we're
working in China in the green space my
responses to a question which was asked
by Ben which was around how can you
become more involved in sustainability
and in the discussions around the
long-term consequences of climate change
I think that it's really important that
the u.s. boy your voice is heard and is
that you continues to be involved in
concussions around this issue because it
affects all of us and at the young
global leader here at the World Economic
Forum I have noticed that's not always
easy to have your voice heard so one of
the initiatives that the young global
leaders has come up with is to create a
campaign around water which we believe
is one of the most fundamental issues
affecting our generation and is a
cornerstone not only of the issues and
debate around food but also around
energy and fundamental to the
discussions around climate change so we
have created a task force and we are
building a social media campaign a
campaign in gear towards educating and
encouraging participation from young
people in the debate publicly around the
water issue so it's not enough for
policymakers and regulators to have
discussions around water and the water
impact on society we believe that it's a
sober order that we have people
fundamentally affected by issues
relating to quarter have an important
avoidance Internet campaign so the young
global leaders has put together this
campaign we are rolling it out in 2012
but we are looking for participation
this year so it will encourage 12
million people young people all of us to
get together to really have our voice
heard and make the regulated
legislators and policymakers and the
decision-makers in our communities start
to create some measures to protect our
water resources I look forward to having
your participate we've created a website
it's called ygl water.org that's why GL
water.org please go online and sign up
to participate in our campaign and we'll
be in touch with more details about the
actions that you can take to preserve
our water supplies together we really
can make a difference thanks